Campen und Wandern im Wald, Sonnen am Pool
- und das alles nackt.
In diesem Naturisten-Camp im Süden Frankreichs
wissen Urlauber die Ruhe und vor allem ihre
Nacktheit zu schätzen.
Besonders bei jungen Leuten liegt die Freikörperkultur
wieder voll im Trend.
"Die Klischees fallen, man gewöhnt sich an
das Nacktsein, wie wenn man einen Bikini anhätte.
Es ist ein bisschen schwer, sich komplett
frei zu machen für die erste Stunde, aber
dann geht’s."
Lange Zeit waren Naturistencamps einem älteren
Stammpublikum vorbehalten.
Doch diese Zeiten ändern sich.
Mittlerweile sind die Camping- und Ferienanlagen
besonders bei jungen Familien mit Kindern
beliebt.
"Wenn wir hier sind, können wir tun, was
wir wollen.
Wir müssen keine Kleidung tragen, wir fühlen
uns wohl in unserer Haut.
Sicher ist keiner perfekt, aber das ist hier
auch völlig unwichtig.
Und für die Kinder ist es das Tollste – sie
lieben es."
Seit Jahren steigt die Zahl der Nackturlauber
weltweit.
Mit mehr als vier Millionen Gästen pro Jahr
ist Frankreich mittlerweile das Urlaubsland
Nummer eins, wenn es um FKK-Erholung geht.